[Music]
okay so is that we already Jenn yes all
right terrific well before I open the
hearing I'd like to welcome everybody
back to the House Education Committee
and and unfortunately our our fearless
leader represented miler is is down in
Boston an appointment today and it's not
going to be able to be with us but as
you've probably all heard he's doing
very very well he's being very very his
body is responding very very well to his
treatments and and he's been sharing
this information out but but his you
know things are looking looking really
good his doctors are very pleased and
and and so I want to thank you on behalf
of mouth for for sending all your good
vibes and good thoughts and and and
because it's that and everything is
working so so so hopefully that will
continue in that very positive direction
and I hope everybody's been been healthy
and remaining healthy and active during
during this time and and continues to do
that I'd like to welcome a few a few
people to the Education Committee this
afternoon we've got let's see
representative Alexander subbing in for
representative Boehm so welcome Joe from
from across the road where are you Joe
yeah there you are there are great great
thanks for being here this afternoon
I'd like to recognize representative
Ford who
some subbing in for representative
Daugherty so sue thanks for for being
here this afternoon and also
representative Heath who's who's sitting
in for a chair mile or so Mary thanks
very much for for being here today so
well unless there's any other
announcements to make it this time is
there any should I should I open the
hearing and then read the our protocol
statement is that the order of
operations here Jim I'm I'm not sure
that it matters okay
well then then why don't I why don't I
why don't I read our realm are an
opening statement they're really sort of
talks about the policy and the rules of
the road behind behind this meeting and
its adherence to the governor's
executive order number 12 start with
that and then we'll do a we'll do a roll
call attendance and then we'll open the
hearing is that fair enough
all right real good so so here's some
remarks with regards to the house
education public hearing today on 2 9
2020 as chair of the House Education
Committee I find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor as
a result of the coated 19 pandemic and
in accordance with the governor's
emergency order number 12 pursuant to
executive order number 20 2004 this
public body is authorized to meet
electronically please note that there is
no physical location to observe and
listen contemporary contemporaneously to
this meeting which were thought which
was authorized pursuant to the
governor's executive to pursue it to the
governor's emergency order however in
accordance with the emergency order I am
confirming that we are a providing
public access to the meeting by
telephone with additional access
possibilities by video or other
electronic means we are utilizing zoom
for this electronic meeting
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting through this platform and
the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
clicking on the following website
address and and that is HTTP colon two
forward slashes zoom 0m us /j as in
Jackson forward slash nine nine two
seven one seven nine three seven three
seven that's the link I'm not gonna read
it again or by dialing one of the
following phone numbers and here's a
couple of them here one nine - nine -
zero five six zero nine nine or one
three zero one seven one five eight five
nine - so that's the first part be
providing public notice of the necessary
information for accessing this meeting
we previously gave notice to the public
of the necessary information for
accessing the meeting including how to
access the meeting using zoom or
telephonically this information is
printed in the house calendar C
providing a mechanism for the public to
alert the public body during the meeting
if there are problems with access if
anyone has a problem of course it's kind
of be hard to get that from listening to
this this announcement but it's printed
in the calendar if anyone has a problem
please call two seven one 3600 or email
HCS at ledge state dot n h us finally D
a journeying the meeting if there if the
public is unable to access the meeting
so in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be a
jury didn't reschedule Jennifer or this
for have there been any technology
issues that you're aware of or inability
to act we have 20 attendees who managed
to come
I haven't heard of anyone having
troubles that weren't resolvable okay
thanks very much miss for I'd like to
introduce the the staff who are on the
meeting to assist us Jen for our House
Committee researcher is our meeting host
this afternoon
additional House committee service staff
providing support are Brad Greenland
Pam smart Lee and Christina Dyer this is
a public hearing on Senate joint
resolution 1 and on Senate bill 514 a
copy of the bills and any other relevant
materials have been posted on the main
page of the General Court website under
the heading remote meetings please note
that all votes that are taken during
this meeting shall be done by roll call
vote and let's start the meeting by
taking a roll call attendance when each
member states their presence please also
indicate whether there is anyone in the
room with you during the meeting and
let's see don't we also have two they're
I can't I think everyone tends to yeah
yeah okay maybe maybe that's why I'm
thinking that so anyway please indicate
if anyone's in the meeting in the room
where you are which is required under
the right to know
so with that I guess I will call to
order the public hearing on Senate joint
resolution 1 and today is Tuesday June
9th at approximately approximately 112
p.m. and like to ask the clerk to call
you
I can't hear ya Jen can you okay
so the roll representative Mary Heath
present here in Manchester I'm home
alone and I'm here for Mel miler
representative miler Thank You
representative barbara shaw here alone
inside anyway representative cornell
here alone in my house representative
representative Tim relay I'm here in my
kitchen table in Northampton New
Hampshire and I do have under my
supervision two minor children and two
I think he's good on mute maybe I'm
present here in Concord law in the room
Thank You representative Mullin I am
here in Bedford and I am alone in the
room Thank You representative real right
here alone
Thank You representative alone I'm here
in Epping my wife may be walking through
the room occasionally okay
representative Woodcock here by the Saco
instead of Conway and my wife will be
coming in and out all right
representative lad here in Haverhill
I am here in my home office it in Tufton
borough and I am lone representative
Eliot I'm here in my apartment with my
representative Alexander I'm here in
representative wolf representative wolf
I just unmuted thank you okay I'm here
in my office in New London there may be
some ups people or something like that
to come in and out okay
you
I am here in Pittsfield and only
occasionally I have two rather large
representative Lud kiss I can see you
yeah represented Lucas appears to be
connected and she is not muted on my end
at least got a couple here
representative Lu no I reported from
Hopkinton with Ozzy the long-haired
dachshund okay and I am here
reporting from Georgia's Mills with -
but sometimes Sparky dogs so a
representative Leykis it looks like her
screen might be frozen I'm gonna ask um
our staff person who's helping with
technology to try and reach out to her
I'm not sure if her cell phone number
just want to check on representative
foresight again he is here or not I'm
not
okay so until representative like this
is unfrozen looks like everybody's here
except representative Forsyte okay thank
you very much represent Tanner Jen
should how long should we wait a minute
for to see if we can get representative
Lee kisses situation cleared here that's
really up to you if you want to wait
will be like I said we'll be trying to
reach her in the background to make it
sure that she's reconnected properly
would you put Yuri on it's not clear how
long that might take okay why don't we
why don't we do that and we'll proceed
into the hearing with Senate joint
resolution one and I'd like to welcome
senator Kahn the prime sponsor of the
bill to to join us I've just promoted
senator Kahn to panelists and you should
be able to hear from him okay fantastic
so welcome senator Kahn to the remote
House Education Committee Thank You mr.
chairman thank you for convening your
your committee it's you got a large
group there but you've done so
successfully I am Jake on I am the state
senator in district 10 representing
Keene and 14 other towns in Cheshire
County I am presenting Senate joint
resolution one to you that was adopted
by the Senate on February 6th as a
little bit of background to this I serve
on the joint legislative committee on
administrative rules chaired by your
representative have bill hatch
and at the request of the gel car
chairman representative hatch I did
introduce the Senate joint resolution
[Music]
asking for which which followed up on
the gel car final objection to education
that final objection which was entered
by gel car on October 17th of 2019
followed a series of conversations that
and presentations that gel car received
on Board of Education rules
1,400 the findings which are became part
of the Senate joint resolution include
that the education rules 1,400 were
contrary to the Legislature's intent
when the legislature adopted RSA 193 e
to a 5 roman 5 a and that it was
contrary to the general statutory
purpose clause in RSA 193 II 1 and 2 so
hopefully you're familiar with the
curriculum rules that are a part of 193
E the contrary to legislative intent was
cited in a couple of different ways in
the gel car report and the contrary to
the overall general purpose clause of
193 E was also cited in the gel car
report and it violates the general
purpose clause because the statute
delegates to school districts the
responsibility for specific curriculum
for which credit is granted so this was
to use that as a means to grant to the
State Board of Education the authority
to grant up to one-third of all credit
towards a student's graduation but a gel
car found in its final objection that
that is that that 5b section does not
give the board authority to require a
school district to grant credit for
programs or courses when the school
district itself did not approve the
curriculum so the final objection asked
that the General Court undertake a
resolution and that was done on February
6th introduced by and passed by the
Senate that prohibits the Board of
Education from adopting and 1400 which
is embodied here in this Senate joint
resolution 1 and this resolution says
that the legislature shall consider
altering 193 e to a 5 B D so that it is
clear in its intent on what authority
that Clause gives to the Board of
Education and I I'd say that the
legislature both in the house and the
Senate have introduced legislation to
follow through on this joint resolution
the house did so through representative
Tanner's House bill 14:54 and in the
Senate through senator Diaz bill which
you will hear shortly
Senate bill 514 so with that
introduction
I glad to answer any questions committee
has and hope that you will recommend and
ought to pass on Senate joint resolution
one thank you very much senator Kahn um
to members of the committee have have
questions for the senator represent core
deli
Thank You mr. chairman Thank You senator
for being here wherever here is
questioning that I think you were
relating credits to curriculum of the
school but isn't it in statute and rules
that credits are based on competencies
thanks for the question no I that the
statutes are very clear that it is the
responsibility of the school district to
establish how credits are earned many
credits can be earned in a variety of
different ways they make me earn through
internship or work based learning or so
we those are specified in the statute
either by raising your hand on as a as a
panelist or if you want to get my
attention go like that to seeing none
thank you very much senator Kahn Oh
represent of lad was that a hand raised
it was sort of a pass through the screen
but I've always had a problem with the
how the folks on gel car are responding
to what they think is the intent of this
legislation or are the learning
everywhere everywhere program according
to statute and if we're looking at the
same sections that Senator Kahn is
referencing five a and B 5 B has a
statement which I'd like to have senator
Kahn respond to please says the State
Board of Education shall adopt rules
pursuant to 541 a and those rules are
approved by gel car and they were
relative to the approval of alternate
programs for granting credit leading to
graduation so it gives am i right in
saying that the State Board has
determine alternate programs that lead
to graduation by awarding credit so Rick
represent lat
my understanding is we've got the chair
of JL Karp coming up next that anything
related to 541 aim might be better
directed to the chair of JL car also
representative Hatch's from the north
country okay wait I don't the heels here
yeah is that okay with you senator we
can but but I'm happy to let you respond
to that though yeah and if you let me
well it's it so to make clear what 5b
does is it says pursuant to issuing
rules relative to approval of alternate
programs it doesn't say that the Board
of Education shall have the authority to
grant credit towards graduation it's
that it will develop rules for
alternative programs and the clause
that's just before it just can't be
ignored it's it makes it very clear that
it is the responsibility of a school
board its teachers and administrators to
identify the best way for students to
acquire the knowledge skills in
curriculum essentially what what
representative Cordell II was
identifying earlier so there was a
pretty clear distinction established
within the same section just different
subsections III just didn't we did not
see how it could be controverted either
through the general purpose clause of
193 e2a
or through the section that as a whole a
and B both are are defining let me also
say that this is this action here is a
little bit odd in its you know a lot of
hatch talk to you about the timing on
this but I think the action by the House
Education Committee is needing to be
completed within this month by June 26th
in order to comply with the guidelines
established in 541 a and 541 a is very
we're as to how it defines the
establishing of rules and and these
violating legislative intent or or
exceeding legislative intent I should
say and the contrary to general purpose
statements these are these are very
clear within the guidelines of 541 eight
all right mr. chairman seeing no more
questions any other questions for the
center we've got we've got a hand raised
from sin from represent cordially Thank
You mr. chairman
and Hughes senator in the resolution
just looking at the bottom of the first
page where looks like you're doing two
things in this resolution you're
prohibiting the State Board of Education
from taking action and also putting a
mandate on the general court general
is really that the purpose of this
resolution and I had thought that
resolutions had a different purpose
other than requiring an action of this
type it is a requirement in 541 a if
when entering a final objection that the
legislature also remedy that the the
reasons for it and that is what's being
done here thank you very much senator
con see no further questions thank you
very much for your time oh I'm sorry
there's no there's a hand up from
represent of Eliot yes I'm reading the
last paragraph of the bill itself right
and it says that Senator to you I want
some clarification here and I'm gonna
add the word state when I use the word
board as opposed to the local board
because I feel that this gives more
authority to the local board and less
authority to the State Board of
Education so it goes like this that the
general Court shall clarify RSA 193 II
by legislation that one the rulemaking
authority of the State Board of
Education in RSA 193 e to a V B does or
does not give the State Board authority
to require that school districts grant
credit for courses or programs when the
district
did not itself approve the curriculum
and two that RSA 93 e to a V B therefore
does or does not authorize the State
Board to require a school local district
board to accept the credit if it chooses
not to would you explain that to me does
it or does it not authorize the board do
you have the bill in front of you
senator I do and a glad to explain that
during the gel car hearings and the
final objection it was a request that
the legislature affirm one way or the
other whether the State Board has this
Authority or not that's why I made
reference to the two bills that have
passed from the house to the senator
from the Senate to the house that both
are trying to clarify that authority
well what do you think does it doesn't
mean further question whether question
mr. chair inquire thank you briefly very
briefly in your opinion does it or does
it not give the authority to the school
district to make the final decision is
this a local control bill or not you
know what I'm gonna I'm gonna take that
one represented Elliott what this does
is is directs the general court to
consider a legislation to clarify the
intent the next bill we're gonna hear
about is is a version of that of that
clarity so you may want to look for that
in in Senate bill 514 okay okay yeah we
good senator Kahn thank you very much
for your time this afternoon
Thank You mr. chairman good luck all
right thanks
next I would like to to call on
representative hatch the chair of the
joint legislative committee on
administrative rules just promoted
representative hatch he should appear in
our lineup soon and it looks like
representative Lycus is reconnecting
we can hear you representative you hear
good morning great
well welcome representative hatch to
have such occasion and thanks for your
time this afternoon to testify on Senate
joint resolution 1 Thank You mr. chair
and thank you for your attention and
thank you to the committee for hearing
this issue I'm representative William
hatch
I represent 15 communities in
unincorporated areas including the
beautiful town of Gorham and Shelburne I
also served on Finance as vice chair of
division 1 and in the past I've served
on ways and means as vice-chair I'm
currently chair of gel car which I see
some of the members there had served on
gel car like representative land and are
familiar with it but I find most people
really do not fully understand the role
of gel car in what it does and doesn't
do and I was just asked to speak to this
and and what I will do is I'll just
briefly describe what gel car is my
understanding of the parameters that
were thunder and
why were there what I will not do is I
will not discuss the policy and that's
not what we do in gel car it's not a
policy committee in fact it's rather
unique it consists of five members of
the Senate and five individuals from the
house and that comprises the committee
of gel car and its purpose is is to
review a minute straight-up rules
submitted by other departments or
agencies throughout the state and the
primary function is to assure that those
rules promulgated by the different
entities do follow under statute and do
follow legislative intent through those
statutes how that's done is it's an
arduous task we have three to four
attorneys as part of gel car very
qualified individuals if you're
experienced in very thorough and and I
need to stress that I'm always amazed as
to how thorough the gel car staff is in
going through these rules in the submit
very lengthy reports a lot of reading as
to and and they speak to whether or not
these rules comply where they don't
comply where they may or may not need
improvement and as a committee we get
those reports from the staff attorneys
attorneys we review them during our gel
card meetings and then we dispel we vote
on two positive actions and some of
those the positive actions are is we
could vote to accept the rule as
submitted and that's the most common one
we can review the rules and either from
attorney notes or our own experiences we
can grant a conditional approval to the
agency and we might have some
prerequisites before those rules are
incorporated we might have some added
items we might have some edited items
but again under 541 a it's very exhaust
in we had to stay in very close
parameters for these different positive
actions and through the years in gel car
and I'm sure reckoning recalling a
representative lab we hit them all and
and nothing's done lightly yet I should
say then the other part of the
dispositive action we can do is we could
have a preliminary objection to the rule
we can state why we object to the rule
and on a preliminary objection the rule
goes back to the agency to either fix
address or renegotiate why the committee
objects to the rule and they have 90
days to bring it back to the committee I
believe it's 90 with its editing or
Corrections or changes to comply with
the committee's request and really the
committee's request we're very careful
about it are always based on 541 a and
statute then there's a final objection
saying in some cases and this is what
we're dealing with now with the 1400
rules the committee has a final
preliminary objection and then a final
objection in the agency doesn't see the
necessity to edit those rules to comply
with 541 a and and again I I have to say
that gel car is doesn't take actions in
my experience unless there's very strong
footing and very strong statute
authority to do so and that's again one
of the primary functions of gel cars to
assure that there's statutory authority
to take whatever actions the agency want
to takes wants to take through rules and
actually whatever actions gel car takes
we follow 5:1 541 a very closely there's
four areas for objections I
for dispositive actions and and one of
them is it's very important it's looked
at if we've met legend if the rules that
are being submitted meet legislative
intent in other words does it does it
follow what's in the statute and does it
conform with the statute we also look at
fiscal impact rule named fall statute in
terms of intent but it's filed through
fiscal notes because they do get fiscal
notes the patiska limp act of these
rules as submitted is concerning our
public interest does it meet public
interest that's another area where there
could be objection to the rule submitted
so I think I think I hit him and then
then what's happened with this rule it
was determined that it did not meet
legislative intent Jenny spoke to that
briefly but there's there are certain
things that were for an example in this
rule that were just it's explicit in the
statute as to why the action the Board
of Education wanted to take was not
authorized under statutes and it was
very clear from our staff attorneys and
jail card and that's what moved the
committee to have the final objection so
when that happens and there's still an
unyielding by the agency or the State
Department to conform the rules to what
we believe statute states they should we
come up to the joint resolution which
stops those rules from going forward as
submitted for a period of time
everything we do in gel car is on a time
clock so to speak raaaah
and it starts me
once we vote on those actions to be
taken and and here we are now with the
joint resolution it's gone through the
Senate into that house and just as a
brief historical review since 76 are
thereof or 96 maybe yeah sorry
since 1996 on your gel car there's been
up constantly 5,000 rules are reviewed
by the committee and out of those 5,000
rules there's been only 20 joint
resolutions found necessary I I've been
on gel car for not sure how long more
than a decade anyways plus and the my
experience who has been has been only
one other joint resolution so out of
those 20 joint resolutions
three-quarters of them or 15 of them
once it was voted on by the committee to
take making joint resolution the agency
or the department with jewelr rules as
submitted so what that caused is no
further action needed to be taken the
resolutions did not have to be presented
to both houses the issue is resolved
five of them did go forward and three of
them went the full course up to the
governor's desk then signed and put into
action and again why I'm just getting a
little historical review of joint
resolutions this is not an action taken
lightly this is not an action that
anybody really prefers to do but
nevertheless the importance of it it's
paramount
I think and that's why we're taking this
action now just just to put things maybe
in perspective a little bit gel car a
nonpartisan body and as I stated our
purpose is to assure the things can
with legislative intent things conform
with the statute in my years on gel car
I could not even guess how many times I
voted in favor of a rule I submitted
that I was was so against the policy
that it was speaking to I was so against
the action that was taken but it did
follow legislative intent and it did
fill the purpose that we as a
legislative body voted to take forward
in the majority so that's that's why it
is what it is
and that's why we have to take sometimes
these actions and and I think that's why
it's very important we really need to be
careful about allowing any M&P within
state government to take actions without
the proper to authority and some I heard
a couple members of this committee read
a couple things that seeing what the
board of education was doing was
appropriate but just these things have
been looked at they looked and looked at
by staff eternity attorneys and please
know there's been times that some of
these things were taken to the Supreme
Court and adjudicated and what was what
the finding was when a item is taken out
of context and that's what some of these
they believe that some of these
statements are they were being utilized
as Authority that they were taking the
statue or the phrase out of context and
utilizing that to say that they had the
authority to do what they were doing and
and they don't actually so anyways with
that I think the chairs thank the
committee for listening and and I will
entertain a question or so only on what
Dzhokhar dozen doesn't do I will not
entertain question on policy and I will
not debate statute with that thank you
mr. chair and thank you very much
chairman hatch questions for for
represented hatch I see a representative
cordeliers ass and up go ahead
Thank You mr. chairman
question representative thank you for
being here I was looking at walk back up
you mentioned that a joint resolution
prohibits actions for a period of time
and I also checked with the house clerk
who said that that what deadlines
without deadlines there would not be any
action taking taking place I don't see
any period of time within this joint
resolution would you explain that I'm
not sure I understand your question the
the curated time doesn't have to be with
them joint resolution the period times
are dictated by 541 a all right so we
have just like anything or most things
within the legislature and I think I
stated in explaining what gel cart does
everything we do once we start ADA
positive dispositive action we're on a
clock an agency's on the clock so for
example for this joint resolution under
the current clock unless I as chair and
granted a waiver for that clock has to
be disposed of through legislative
action by the 26th of June per se now
and I I don't know that I understand
stood your quick didn't exactly or not
but that's what I'm when I'm speaking to
the plot timeframe that's what I'm
speaking to or observed cordially your
follow-up yes thank you go on to the
next part of the resolution you talked
about joint resolutions I think
representative and a little background
on them I
was struck by the fact that this
resolution requires the general court to
take certain action how many times have
there been joint resolutions requiring
an action by the general court
I have no absolutely no idea and I don't
even know if that question is germane to
the action we've taken a resolution can
particularly from Dzhokhar the joint
resolutions are a little different than
what we normally used to they're there
for very serious actions to be taken by
the general court it's not just stating
our displeasure with something or
pleasure with something like many joint
resolutions may do that is put into
place for a deposit of action and it is
definitive so thank you are the is this
a follow-up purpose out of core delhi or
is this a new question
a new question just I just want to check
to see if anybody else has a further
question to ask all right seeing none
represented cordially thank you thank
you mr. chairman representative from
what I read one of the gel cards actions
was that it was your basis for
legislative intent that statute
delegates responsibility to districts
for curriculum for which grant credit is
granted but I saw in the Department of
Education response and I believe it to
be true that there is nowhere in statute
or rules that a student is required to
correct to complete specific curriculum
in order to receive credit
and in reality credits are based on
competencies not auricular so I'm not
sure how you determined what the intent
of the the rules were that you were
objecting to just I I think I I may have
mentioned that particularly in this set
of rules of 1400 as submitted by the
agencies and the authorizations that
they utilized for these rules they cited
different things on a statue
individually as opposed to that statue
as a whole and that's what I meant by
taking it out of context and and again
I'm not going to debate our essays or
the meaning of them we have three and
four very capable staff attorneys on gel
card that we rely on heavily not that
everything they submit to us is accepted
by us as a committee but we rely on them
heavily and and they are incredibly and
I can't say this enough because I say it
often they are incredibly thorough and
that has been adjudicated by the
committee and I'm not going to debate it
but that's where we are
thank you further questions
representative Ladd
I got three more minutes my bride just
came in the upstairs this may be the
last question for okay I thought it was
pretty cold out there in North Country
there it was I still see white Rick when
I look out my back window so I got fired
the fireplace right beside me okay I've
looked through 193 E and I can make the
real pretty solid an assumption that it
is statutory intent that all students
have an opportunity for an adequate
education agreed
yeah I I'm not even gonna speak to that
Rick okay oh then I could I'm not even
gonna go there
let me follow that up then I'm looking
at another portion of statute it says
competency-based strategies provide
flexibility in the way that credit can
be earned in a way that's that's not
even right what's nice is why why was
gel car in the position where they're
striking down another alternate pathway
offline online be it whatever it might
be community-based where a student can
achieve these competencies through the
learn everywhere program why was that
struck down because it's to me it's in
mind with the intent of those several
areas I'll just I'll just say this for
the entire committee if I may into that
question go to the gel car website
everything's very clear there and Rick
with you your abilities it probably will
take you about five minutes to read the
notes off that the answer the question
you just asked me Thank You mr. chair
okay thank you
seeing no further questions thank you
very much chairman hatch for for being
with us this afternoon
Thank You mr. K I hope I was helpful and
it's good seeing a lot of you guys stay
warm up north
yeah next I would like to to recognize
Commissioner L blue who is offering to
thank you I'm on video but I'm not sure
if I'm gonna be promoted on the football
month phone but am I going to promote it
on video too because I don't want to
give you guys parallel processing here
you've certainly been promoted as a
panelist so I don't know great we will
go ahead and I don't see myself jump on
screen so I'm going to go ahead and get
started then in terms of the testimony
thank you for the record Frank a tableau
Commissioner of Education and appreciate
that you all have joined us by video
today and are addressing these important
matters by way of comments I've got
another meeting that I need to be at I
know you have deep our Senate joint
resolution one but then you'll be
hearing SB five one four I have
submitted testimony to you on both of
those both on sjr one as well as SB five
one four to encourage you to take a look
at those because this is the sjr hearing
I will limit my comments principally not
to policy but to the gel car process
would encourage you as well to read the
many pages of information that I have
provided to gel car as well as to this
committee in response to the gel car
actions and now the actions before this
legislature body so as context and I
think it's important that we have the
context the department and the board
have been responding to a specific
statute passed by the legislature that
statute states very simply the State
Board of Education shall adopt rules
pursuant to 541 a doesn't give anybody
an option relative to the approval of
alternative programs for granting credit
leading to graduation
this mandate to the board is really
quite unambiguous and both the board and
the agency understands the important
responsibility that we have to have
fidelity to the statute in adopting
rules it states that the board shall
adopt rules
the legislature has ordered the board to
create rules in response to this statute
and the board has
edie 1400 testimony when RSA 193 e2a 5b
was passed made clear how the agency
understood this law and how it would be
implemented that is part of the record
edy 1400 is consistent with that
testimony attempts were made during the
last legislative session to modify the
agency's understanding of RSA 193 hua 5b
and those were not successful that means
that the this legislative body affirmed
that the agency's understanding of the
law was appropriate it's interesting
that representative hatch talks about
the JAL car being a non partisan board
and I appreciate the long history of the
JAL car attorneys and the nonpartisan
approach that it has taken to many
pieces of legislation in the past in
this particular instance it is important
to point out that every vote that was
taken on the learn everywhere rules on
edy 1400 was strictly along partisan
lines so hardly nonpartisan in that
sense the law in addition to stating
that we shall adopt rules also said it
shall adopt rules for the approval of
alternative programs what is really
interesting if you're in New Hampshire
we have a great set of very wide and
flexible rules for all of our public
schools whether those are traditional or
charter to be able to develop and
implement lots of different varieties of
student programming the agency's
understanding of RSA 183 e2 a 5b is that
an alternative or different program be
established not simply a really
reiteration of that which already exists
an IDI 1400 accomplishes this goal in
the feedback that we received from JAL
car in several instances whether it was
in comments or formal responses they say
why don't you just do this or why don't
you just do that well because those were
not alternatives those existed
in statute and enroll today so they
would not meet the legislative intent of
this rule and then the final aspect of
the law that I in the statute that you
all passed that I want to point out is
it says it is for granting credit
leading to graduation and this phrase is
quite clear and contains no subject
subjunctive expression or uncertainty
credits are granted and credits lead to
graduation
there is no conditional furbished in RSA
193 e to a 5 B such that the agency
could understand that credits may be
granted or that credits may lead to
graduation the law is very clear
edie 1400 is limiting in that it doesn't
say says we have to lead to credit
leading to graduation it does not result
in graduation but only credits that are
earned result in leading to graduation
this was actually one of the points that
was addressed in the testimony with gel
car and I want to just quote one of the
gel car members representative Schmidt
who raised a question and you see that
he said quote since the diploma is
granted in the name of and on the
authority of the local school board to
the degree that elements of it would be
effectively forced in against their will
is that not going to cause trouble in
the long run and what I would tell you
is this is a program for earning credit
and it does not trample on the local
responsibilities where's Bob Elliott on
my screen local school districts have
the responsibility to determine what the
requirements are for graduation this
program allows students an alternative
program for accumulating credits that
lead to graduation from that high school
so local control is fully preserved by
representative Elliott and I hope that
that is understood as you begin to
consider these actions now the we've
talked a little bit about
competency-based education and one of
the questions that came up in senator
Kahn's
testimony was dealing with you know it
said that the schools can't create the
curriculum and I'm not wandering into
policy so I'll be very careful here but
it's very interesting that the rules
support the opportunities students can
get correct get credits from a lot of
other curricular places because credits
are granted based on competency and I
think it's important for this committee
to go back and look at the system of
education that we have representative
land reference did you know we want to
create opportunities for all of our
students to be successful to earn
credits in all kinds of places and if
this pandemic has done nothing else it
has emphasized the importance of making
sure that we meet the needs of all of
our students the US Department of
Education defines competency or
personalized learning approaches this
way
it says transitioning away from seat
time in favor of a structure that
creates flexibility allows students to
progress as they demonstrate mastery of
academic content this is the Jellico
process right I'm not on for thirty five
five one four I think it is but so
reflecting on the continued assertion by
glck are linking curriculum and credit
it leaves one with the impression that
gel car remains unfamiliar with the idea
of competency or personalized learning
at its foundation competency or
personalized learning asks the question
what has a student master learn
everywhere program I understand you know
so the department recognizes the
importance and the validity of the gel
car process and its feedback on the
proposed IDI 1,400 rules we have
carefully considered those objections
have made appropriate amendments to the
preliminary objections in the proposed
DD 1400 rules and
been responsive to gel car throughout
the process what we have also done is
achieve fidelity to RSA 193 e to a 5 B
and fidelity to the overall purpose of
RSA 193 e and these rules should be
passed into effect for students in New
Hampshire because they follow the
legislative intent and they have for
well over a year now and it's only
because it's been stuck in this gel car
process that we have not been able to
create opportunities for our students
here in New Hampshire so then I will
stop my comments and let you guys move
on but I'll take questions if anybody
has any thank you very much commissioner
seeing none thank you very much
commissioner for joining us this
let's see according to my list Jen there
was potentially representative from the
elo network that wanted to testify but I
don't know who that is we have we have
them here I can promote them now I'm her
name they are they wishing to forum it
was somewhat unclear from the message um
would you would like to ask her her name
is Donna Coulter um yeah I mean if she
can can can attendees raise their hand
to indicate I guess on the alternative
is there another member of the New
Hampshire elo network that would would
care to offer live testimony that's the
only person that I saw that group they
may be rejoined as they had been with us
and we'll check again a little short yep
I'd like to like to invite mr. Donnell
to join us here she is let's see we
getting video we got audio this fellow
can you hear us there we go thank you
very much for joining us this afternoon
Thank You mr. chair members of the House
Education Committee for the record my
name is Megan Tuttle president of Nea
New Hampshire representing 17,000
educators across the state of New
Hampshire and I'm here before you
remotely in support of Senate joint
resolution 1 we support the final
objection and this joint resolution
issued by gel car and its reasons for
doing so at 1400 is contrary to the
statute it was passed under and that the
State Board under long-standing law does
not have the ability to require a school
district to accept credit senator Kahn
some of my other colleagues who express
these objections I would simply like to
add that there's an important practical
reason why New Hampshire's followed
local control of credit granting and
it's statutes for so long because it
values the role of the educator in the
process of student learning in addition
as classroom teachers we must meet
specific requirements go through the
process of applying and meeting the
standards necessary to be certified
educators so excuse me miss well I just
I just want to keep this fairly tight to
the so so you've you've you've mentioned
that existing law you know provides
credit granting Authority now you're
sort of justifying what that why that
existing law is in place but if we can
try to keep it really close to the to
the jail car structure yet let me just
basically the public elo programming
programs that we have are operating
under the rules that are already
approved by gel car for alternative
programs and so we're supporting the
joint resolution as written okay thank
you very much mr. Hubbell are there are
there questions for um for Megan Tuttle
was that a hand
representative Alexander we stop
pressing something all right
no let's see screen any further
questions
seeing none thank you very much for
joining us this afternoon
thank you um let's see so I guess one
last call if we've got anybody from the
New Hampshire yellow Network no okay or
anybody else that's wishing to testify
the only other person I had marked down
was Miss marine parole she submitted
written testimony and I see her in the
list I'm not sure that she wants to
speak perhaps miss pearl with you could
raise your hand if you're interested in
speaking so I'm going once going twice
going three times are you seeing any
hands raised Jen I'm not not if there's
anyone on the phone that would like to
raise their hand the function is star
okay then we will close the hearing what
clock has raised his hand what's that
representative Woodcock has raised his
hand um
yeah go ahead represent Woodcock
would say Thank You mr. chairman
just one quick comment elo did submit
written testimony today okay thank you
um so so I believe all the written
testimony is being transmitted to and
has been sent to committee members
corrected that's correct
and and miss pearl has raised her hand
in the intervening time okay so um so
and Miss prahl could we bring this prole
in to testify she is unmuted she still
works muted here we go hello hello miss
brawl welcome to health education if you
could introduce yourself and then share
with us some thoughts my name is Maureen
Crowell and I am a mother of three
children who were educated in New
Hampshire public schools and went on to
UNH I am testifying in support of this
joint resolution because I believe that
the State Department the State Board of
Education has overstepped their
authority in expecting local school
districts to grant graduation credits
based on learning sites venues providers
outside their sphere of influence I also
believe that these same local school
districts have the responsibility to the
taxpayers in their community
to debt these sites and to accredit them
and to oversee them my children have
taken advantage of the extended learning
opportunities and gotten science credit
and I believe that the school district
or I know that the school district
provided oversight of the goals of that
program and the granting of credit
towards graduation I think that this is
a redundant program that's been offered
by the State Board of Education and
lastly I would suggest that they take
the money to implement such a program
and extend the extended learning
opportunities in property poor towns who
probably don't have the level of
extended learning opportunities that
many of us have and that's what I want
to say thank you mrs. Prall um would you
be willing to take a question sure
okay representative cordially thank you
thank you and this problem being here I
was just wondering if you had read the
rules that had been proposed by the
department and process for accepting
partners into the yellow program through
the State Board of Education are those
the ones that were posted on the estate
Board of Education website back in well
I thought it was last summer or was it
last fall it was 80 1,400 I don't know
it by number I know that I have I have
read the the bill a while ago follow up
and I actually your children or
participating in yellow
program and getting credits do you have
any idea how many the percentage let's
say of eligible students in the state do
get yellow credits currently I have no
idea yeah yeah I think that's that's
sort of beyond I think I'm just I'm just
a parent I'm doing parents right I
wouldn't expect thank you very much miss
Opoku seeing no other no further
questions and we'll close the hearing on
resolution one I apologize for
interrupting I just wanted to let you
know that while Ms Pro speaking that
Donna KOTOR from the elo network was
able to reconnect if you did want to
hear from her you know I think we just
closed the hearing we've we've heard
quite a bit apologize to miss cooter on
that but we tried a couple of times
there and so with the hearing closed
we're going to actually move into an
exact session and that way we can you
know people who are who are tuning in to
us can can find out what what we've
decided to do with with this piece of
legislation before us and so Jen I think
I before we call to order the executive
session do I read this script again can
I can i when I go through can I just you
know go a providing be providing and
just sort of streamline it a little bit
do I have to have the links read the
links in again that's what we've done
traditionally all right we'll do the
whole thing so so shortly we're going to
begin a house education executive
session today's Tuesday June 9th 2020 is
chair of the House Education Committee I
find that due to the state of emergency
declared by the governor as a result of
koba night
pandemic and in accordance with the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order number 2020
- therefore this public body is
authorized to meet electronically please
note there is no physical location to
observe and listen contemporaneously to
this meeting which was authorized
pursuant to the governor's emergency
order however in accordance with the
emergency order I am confirming that we
are a providing public access to the
meeting by telephone with a ditches with
additional access possibilities by video
or other electronic means here were
those electronic means we are utilizing
zoom for this electronic meeting all
members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaries
contemporaneously during this meeting
through this platform and the public has
access to the contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by clicking on the following
website address HTTP / last zoom dot US
/ j / nine nine two seven one seven nine
three seven three seven or by dialing
one of the following telephone numbers
199 two zero five six zero nine nine or
one three zero one seven one five eight
five nine two so that's the first part
we're also compliant by be providing
public notice of the necessary
information for the for accessing this
meeting we did this by previously gave a
giving notice to the public of the
necessary information for accessing the
meeting including how to access the
meeting using zoom or telephonically
this information is printed in the house
calendar C providing a mechanism for the
public to alert the public body during
the meeting if there are problems with
access so if anybody does have a problem
please call two seven one 3600 or email
us at HCS at Legg at le g dot state n H
dot us
and finally d a-- during the meeting if
the public is unable to access the
meeting any event the public is unable
to access the meeting the meeting will
be adjourned and rescheduled what to
introduce the staff that are on the
meeting
assisting us we Gen for our House
Committee researcher she's the meeting
host addition to most House Committee
service staff providing supporter Brad
Greenland Pam smiling and Christina Dyer
this is an executive session on House
Joint Resolution 1 a public hearing was
held on this bill
earlier today copy of the bill and any
other relevant information having been
posted on the main page have been posted
on the main page of the General Court
website under the heading remote
meetings please note that all votes that
are taken during this meeting shall be
done by roll call vote and we'll start
the meeting by taking roll call into
attendance when each member states their
presence please also indicate whether
there's anyone in the room with you
during the meeting which is required
under the right-to-know law so with that
I will call to order the executive
executive session for Senate joint
resolution 1 and ask the clerk to to
representative Heath representative
okay
yes Mary Heath present and I'm here to
replace representative miler are you
alone I am alone in the room yes in
Manchester New Hampshire representative
Shaw yes alone in Manchester New
Hampshire
present alone in my kitchen in
Manchester New Hampshire representative
Ford I'm here in Easton alone in my
house representative Leigh um present in
Northampton New Hampshire supervising
two minor children representative
Tanner's here I'm alone present along
here in Concord New Hampshire I am here
in Bedford New Hampshire with a cat that
thinks it's a dog representative real
cold real here in goffstown new
hampshire by myself you're in Epping and
with my wife occasionally represented
Woodcock here in Center Carley New
Hampshire and my wife is present in the
room representative Ladd you're in
Haverhill alone representative corps
deli
representative Elliot Hampshire with my
wife
representative Alexander I'm here in
I'm here under New Hampshire by myself
was an occasional UPS man I am here in
Pittsfield New Hampshire alone except
for the accompaniment of two sleeping
dogs since my internet one are you alone
reporting from Hopkinton with mozzie
long-haired dachshund okay great
so we just had a hearing on Senate joint
resolution one and I would take a motion
from let's see we're gonna take a motion
from from representative Mullin of ought
to pass as that motion been seconded by
representative alone and is there we
represent Mullin like to speak to her
motion yeah I'd be happy to speak to my
motion I think that we ought to pass
this resolution and let it go through if
it does nothing else other than clarify
whether or not the State Board of
Education has the rulemaking authority
that ed 1400 claimed that it did I don't
I don't feel like I have any better
answer to the question
now than I did them so I think that the
joint resolution oughta stand
terrific any representative alone any
any further to add on the speaking on
the motion you're muted mark it's just
thumbs up on that so any other anybody
any other members wishing to speak on
the motion about to pass represented
cordeliers is hand up and so does
representative lad IC represent I'm
gonna call on representative Ladd right
I'm glad you need to respond to the
prompt on your screen just let me take
my own little microphone I'll cross it
out
when SB 435 went into effect that's the
initial bill there are several you there
that were present at that time and we've
talked a lot about intent today intent
of that law the basic intent that what
law was to get away from all this seat
time we have in these classrooms right
now in the traditional location it's
about student competency and it's about
varied real-life experiences an outside
tradition outside the traditional walls
and and so we went ahead with that and
the vote on that particular bill came
out 17 to 3 a bipartisan vote in support
of this bill but then all of a sudden
we're hearing all this while this
conflicts with my little school here
being able to approve these credits but
right now we also have credits coming in
from other locations be it through the
military compact or alternative learning
situations that a kid comes into school
transfers in that local school board
hasn't approved the courses those kids
took elsewhere but the courses are
accepted towards graduation
so I'm feeling to see where really what
is the basic underlying cause for these
rules to be denied you know I'm talking
about the rules to start at 1400 and go
through 1407 and there are very clear
rules they specifically state what the
program goals are accountability
rationale it's all there in fact there's
more accountability for this than there
is in many of these classes which are
accepted by a school principal when it
come and when a child moves in so I'm
just feeling understand why we're not
providing the opportunity for an
adequate child right child to all kids
in this state even those kids that are
in schools where they don't have a
person to identify alternative learning
programs or they don't have the funding
to provide that the challenges within
the school because of their zip code and
so once again this committee is denying
educational choice and I think it's a
thank you and I still needed know you're
good okay
I don't think I heard anything that
explains to me the basis for the intent
objection a statute in place is very
clearly the State Board of Education
shall adopt rules relative to the
approval of alternative programs for
credits it's a mandate
it's a Shou that's what the State
suggestions that have been made through
the gel car process they have put in an
approval review process with local ELO
people involved local school board
members involved that has all been done
we heard from the representative car
that he didn't want to discuss the
statutes but seemed to me that that was
his basis for the objections to the
rules so I do not understand the the
reason for this resolution because the
statute has been upheld with subsequent
votes after its passage and it is the
law I don't know what could be clearer
than what is written in the statute and
if anybody else like to share a thought
representative Elliot wanted to ask
Edler stated the Commission stated quote
the State Board shall adopt rules on
both what is the source of that so
you've got the question to the chair
the the source of that is actually the
the reference to the Senate bill that
that that I think I mentioned during
during the commissioners testimony and
he thought I might have been referring
to the next bill but Senate bill 435
from the 2018 session says the State
Board of Education shall adopt rules ,
pursuant to RSA 541 a comma relative to
the approval of alternative programs for
represent bland you've got a you've got
a click that blue one I always see red
and what you got a blue shirt on par me
you got a blue shirt on I know that's
because it's long-sleeve it's cold up
here what you read was correct
it's the RSA 193 econ to Roman 5 a and B
and n B it basically does say that this
is a mandate to the State Board and that
was referenced and that was put into law
with 435 so that the intent was so clear
and yet now we're we're saying well
where's your legislative intent and it
Scullion law it's in statute what this
State Board of Education did is in
accordance with it would one's good
policy and law are you oh dear
ok thanks thanks Rick Donny Thank You
representative Ladd are there further
further thoughts anybody would like to
share before we call the vote
represent Shaw has her hand up represent
Shaw thank you I agree very strongly
with what representative Labs said for
the last four or five years on the
Education Committee we have worked hard
to expand loz to expand opportunities
competency-based learning everything
that we could possibly do to help kids
expand their seat time and all of a
sudden it's lean learn everywhere came
out and it was oh my god this is a
horrible thing I'm sorry but I don't
think there's a question one bit in the
law as to what the intent was for SB 435
or HP whichever SRB 435 anyway and I I
strongly recommend that this that we not
vote in favor of this I think it's very
clear in law and have thought that for
quite a while
thank you any further comments see
seeing none and I will ask the clerk to
call the roll
just to clarify we are the motion is
ought to pass on Senate joint resolution
1 with the motion made by by Mullin and
seconded by five alone so clerk will
please call the roll
yes representative Heath votes yay
representative Shaw no representative
Shaw votes nay representative Cornell
votes yay
representative Ford and Ford
vote yes votes yes representative Lee
okay yes
representative Leigh votes yes
representative Tanner votes yes
representative Ellison yes
representative Ellison votes yes
representative Mullin yes representative
moyen votes yes representative real yes
representative real votes yes
representative alone yes
representative alone votes yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Woodcock votes yes
representative lad
No representative lad votes no
representative Cordell II know
representative Cordell II votes no
representative Eliot no representative
no representative Alexander votes no
representative wolf no representative
wolf votes no representative Allard no
representative Allard votes no
representative for side its absence
representative Leykis no representative
Leykis votes no chairman Liu no yes
journey chairman Liu no votes yes I have
a tally of 11 yes and eight days Senate
joint resolution one is recommended not
to pass by house of decay
I'll call to a close the executive
session on FDR one is is there going to
be Minority Report
oh let's yeah let's represent Vlad yes
and so so let's let's just talk about
that real real quick and representative
Mullen would would you care to write the
are you giving me an option on whether
or not I want to write this committee
report I want to be clear on this yeah
well I'm just confirming I sort of
thought that's what you might be doing
I'm not sure what the what the process
of the procedure is so that that's what
I wanted to talk about in representative
lad will you take care of the Minority
Report or between you and Glen yes so
what I what I'd like you to do if you
could email me and and representative
miler those those by let's see we got
tomorrow maybe by the end of the day
Wednesday oh sure would be a problem
Dave I'll do this one and the next one
we haven't had yet I'm just assuming
we're going to be the minority corps
Delhi will write that one okay okay yeah
I could get if if Mel and I could get
get the reports by the end of the day
Wednesday I think that would be does
that give us time Jen yeah because it's
two weeks to the next what happens
Thursday
well you and representives miler
approved them you can send them to me
and then I'll I'll send them to Karen
for processing
okay fantastic um yeah no matter what
happens on Thursday this can
he needs to finish its work though on
these two bills and we need you know
we've had a an exec session and we're
gonna produce report so so thanks very
much on that so next up we've already
adjourned the exact session okay and and
we're gonna be taking up a public
hearing on Senate bill 514 next and
we're running about 41 minutes behind
but hopefully we can make up some some
time but where we won't be able to make
up time is on the on what I have to read
at the start so I will do my best to
move through it quickly so first I'm
gonna read these remarks and then we'll
we'll open up the earring and and call
the roll again so Jen are we all ready
okay great so this is a public hearing
in House Education for June 9 2020 and
as chair of House Education Committee I
find that due to the state of emergency
declared by the governor as as a result
of the coab in 19 pandemic and in
accordance with the governor's emergency
order number 12 pursuant to executive
order number 20 20-0 for this public
body is authorized to meet
electronically please note that there is
no physical location to observe and
listen contemporaneously to this meeting
which with which was authorized pursuant
to the governor's emergency order
however in accordance with the emergency
order I am confirming that we are a
providing public access to the meeting
by telephone with additional access
possibilities by video or other
electronic things we're doing this by
utilizing zoom for this electronic
meeting all members of the committee and
select legislative staff have the
ability to communicate contemporaneously
during this meeting through this
platform and the public has access to
contemporary contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in the
meeting by clicking on the following
website address HTTP slash slash zoom
u.s. /j
slash nine nine two seven one seven nine
three seven three seven or by dialing
one of the following telephone numbers
one 99205 six zero nine nine or one
three zero one seven one five eight five
nine to be providing public notice of
the necessary information for accessing
the meeting we previously gave notice to
the public of the necessary information
for accessing the meeting including how
to access the meeting using zoom or
telephonically this information is
printed in the house calendar C
providing a mechanism for the public to
alert the public body during the meeting
if there are problems with access if
anyone has a problem please call to 7
130 600 or email at HC s @ l EG dot
state dot n HQ s d a journey in a
meeting if the public is unable to
access the meeting in the event the
public is unable to access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled I'd like to introduce the
staff that are on the meeting assisting
us we have Jennifer for House Committee
researcher and she is our meeting host
additional House committee service staff
providing support are Brad Greenland and
smiling and Christina Dreyer
this is a public hearing on Senate bill
514 a copy of the bill and any other
relevant materials but have been posted
on the main page of the General Court
website under the heading remote
meetings please note that all votes that
are taken during this meeting shall be
done by roll call vote so let's start
the meeting by taking a roll call
attendance when each member states their
presence please also state whether there
is anyone in the room with you during
this meeting which is required under the
right-to-know law so I'll call call to
order the public hearing of Senate bill
514 and ask the clerk to call the roll
for attendance Thank You mr. chair
representative Heath Mary Keith here in
Manchester New Hampshire
here alone and I'm here today in place
of representative Mel Miller
Thank You representative Shaw yes in
yes
in Manchester alone yes I'm here in
Easton alone and representative
representing representative Dave Doherty
Thank You representative Lee yes Tim
relay I'm here in Northampton and I'm
alone with the exception of the two
representative Tanner is here from
Sunapee New Hampshire president I'm
alone here in Concord New Hampshire I am
representative real you're alone in
goffstown new hampshire here in West
Epping on Lake Road with my wife I'm
here instead of calling New Hampshire
and my wife is present in the room Thank
You representative here alone in my
representative Cordell E here alone in
representative Eliot okay
representative Alexander I'm here in
Goffstown and my roommate is in the
mouth
representative wolf I am here in no.1 in
New Hampshire and I will be leaving
shortly because I'm you have a three
o'clock commitment I am here in
Pittsfield alone I'm here alone in
Hudson New Hampshire sitting in my car
underneath the South Tower since my
internet went out reporting from
Hopkinton with Ozzie the long-haired
dachshund so thank you very much Turner
I would like to are we all set with with
tech Jen I believe so okay terrific
with that I would like to invite senator
deej to to join us to introduced Senate
bill 514 hello senator good afternoon
thank you for for joining us and welcome
to virtual House Education Committee
it's good to meet you all and my
compatriots only on the other side it's
good I have only met a few of you so
it's good to see you I am senator gene
Beach from Senate district 9 which
includes 14 towns from Bedford all the
way almost over to the Vermont border
and I am vice chair of Senate Education
and workforce I'm a member of jail carp
I've spent much of my career in
educational media and as a market
consultant and a manufacturer for the
educational software and media
publishing industry I have two children
who have attended both public and
private schools I've served on the
Carmel school board and I have a
master's in public policy from Harvard
Kennedy so we're here today to talk
about
SB 5:14 you've heard all the wise and
wherefore of the reasons that we are
putting forward SB 514 today I have to
say I'm disappointed to hear that some
people seem to think they've made up
their mind even before we present on the
bill and have decided that they're going
to write the Minority Report and it
seems that the person who was assigned
to write the minority report is actually
leaving the meeting so I'm a little
disappointed that we're not going to you
know have a have a real hearing here and
I hope that we will
well no no senator I don't mean to
interrupt you but we always have real
hearings and House education and and
also I do want to point out that that I
believe representative Labs not the one
that said he needed to leave the meeting
early so so you do have our full
attention thank you no I thought he has
signed representative Cordell II who I
thought said oh no no and represent
Cordell II I don't believe is leaving
okay thank you and I didn't mean to
impugn anyone I misheard what was going
on so we've we've put together this new
bill because our understanding of the
legislative intent of 435 was that the
rules would said that the Board of
Education would create rules for
districts to approve alternative
programs not that it would take over the
approval of the program and forced them
on the district to me that was the
simple difference that may not have come
out in the previous hearing but at any
point we have put together legislation
in SB 514 that is not about whether
schools offer alternative programs or
even whether the state school board
offers alternative programs and approves
them it is only about whether districts
are required to it
except the specific alternative programs
that the school board approves so we've
had a lot of talk about yellows and how
wonderful they are
I know public schools are very eager to
offer yellows some of the schools can't
afford the extra staff that are
necessary to offer them and if you had
heard from the head of the elo that
person might have said that most schools
would love to offer yellows if they had
the money to do so and I thought that
the parent who came forward and spoke
about why don't we use the money from
they learn everywhere program to give
the less able schools the ability to
offer yellows that that would be a more
useful use of it made a very good point
I think that what what I bet people who
are not from the educational industry
background as I am may not understand is
that the difference between the State
Approved learn every core program and
what goes on with an elo at the public
school I was also on the Carmel school
board I don't know if I mentioned that
is that with the elo there's close
supervision there's a a person who
either guidance counselor or a teacher
or staff member who has recommended that
yellow for a particular student and as
the student is in that program whether
it's you know learning to weld or it's
more of an industry outreach there is
someone who's watching and checking on
that student and making sure that
there's a good fit going in and talking
to the mentor at the industrial place or
other or the teacher or whatever's going
on outside of the school if there are
problems there's oversight that's an elo
the what what is under the learn
everywhere program is a process where an
outside program that might be offered
like an educational publisher like me it
is approved once every three years I
believe is the actual timing once it's
approved every school in the state would
have been required under the old rule to
accept that program so what we're
suggesting is the State Board approves
programs like that so I as an
educational publisher don't have to go
around to every single school district
in the state and say look at my
wonderful program I think you should
adopt it no we can go to the State Board
of Education and say look at my
wonderful program it's approved once and
every every district then knows that oh
the state's reviewed this we may want to
adopt it we may want to let kids use
this program and that's the difference
between learn everywhere and extended
learning opportunities so what we want
to make clear here is that when
something is approved by the learn
everywhere program that the school
district has the option to say I mean
I'll talk to Bedford it's in my district
and and Sue Ellen is here so if Bedford
says okay well the state has proved this
online calculus calculus light and
that's an option
I have Bedford I don't really want to
have my kids get calculus credit for
online calculus light I'm not going to
accept that program
so what SB 514 is making clear is that
the districts can decide that they don't
want to accept that credit terrific
thank you very much
senator for introducing the bill are
there questions of
senator deechi from members of the
committee you can go ahead and I see
representative lads hand up I know he's
on the phone right now are there uh is
there anybody else that would like to
Rick are you all yeah I just want the
senator to know that what I said the
previous meeting I'm trying to do two
zooms at once right now II D and a over
in the Senate is hearing some
christmas-tree tight bills and so I'm
trying to stay on top of what's going on
there however I do have a question on
this particular bill of the senator I'm
reading the the bill as it was amended
and I'd like to ask no we're in this
bill do I see that the State Board shall
develop a list of vendors which are
accepted or approved I'm seeing that
there's a pre pre approved list
maintained by the board but it doesn't
it just says it will establish a process
to do all this but it doesn't seem that
say that that's going to result in a
list of approved vendors could you
please explain what the intent of this
bill is is somewhat confusing to me
further yes so it will be up to the
school board that are the do e to come
up with the rules which define the
process what we do in in legislation is
to outline what they're able to do given
that they have already defined the
process in 1400 we're expecting that
they'll come up with something very very
similar in fact they could just resubmit
that with just changing the fact that
thank you very much to represent you
know and Senator within the bill then
I'm seeing the capability of a state
board to
welp rules that's being deleted so I'm
still really confused as far as what
what we're trying to do with this bill
you're taking away that deal we are the
state boards ability to make rules
pursuant to alternative education that's
gone by the strike and but you just
mentioned that there would be rules
developed for what you're trying you're
intending to do when a board establishes
a process that involves rules
that's rules are necessary that is the
way a board establishes a process is by
creating rules further questions for the
senator representing core Delhi I see
you have your hand up yes thank you I
wanted to ask about well first Thank You
senator for being here
and you mentioned that's what is full
which is din your district I see he from
the information provided by the
Department of Education that 1% of
eligible students at Bedford of actually
received credits from their yellow
program and on the statewide basis it's
2 percent ever seen credits so do you
think that this program is actually
providing the resources to the students
that are needed and wouldn't the current
program that has been proposed better
provide for the needs of students in
terms of other learning alternative
programs well the Commissioner and I've
had many many long discussions on on
this topic and I know he's very
frustrated
by the level of adoption of yellows but
when I talked to teachers when I talked
to superintendents what they tell me is
that give us the money we'll be happy to
do it but you know we are constantly
being asked to do more and more and more
with less and less and less and it can't
happen so I do not believe that
providing a list of pro of credits again
I can tell you that I of course was a
very scrupulous member of the
educational publishing and
manufacturing industry however there are
a lot of people who of companies who
would love to be able to directly sell
their products and their services to
parents who may opt for these things
without understanding the real value and
out without understanding if they're
right for their child and where they
lead I think you can look at the court
records and see how many for-profit
educational service companies have been
taken to court successfully for
providing this kind of direct directly
sold learning products to parents and to
to students and to veterans and and I
don't think we want that happening in
New Hampshire I think that you know this
is this is a bad idea and this is why I
keep reiterating that we need to keep
local control where the the person knows
the student and the person is overseeing
the quality of the instruction that the
student and how well the students
getting wrong how comfort
students with it I think we need that
kind of personal oversight and you
really are going to open yourself up to
all kinds of issues and I'm not sure
Commissioner IDO blue really he was
never in the educational publishing
industry I'm not sure he really
understands what companies like k-12 and
the commercial vendors want to happen
it's through the kinds of policies they
are putting forward I I think that this
idea of parental choice you know that's
great if the parent is well-educated and
has the time to review the product and
say there are some families that that's
perfect for but to force that and to
make it available to everyone you know
that kind of direct sale i I just think
you are asking for a huge amount of
trouble and I would not recommend it i I
do think that yellows are wonderful
though and maybe we do a higher amount
of them over on this side of the
district I'm in Peterborough by the way
but I I know that money is really the
big issue there Thank You senator
represent of Cordell you yes thank you
I must have the senator based on what
you just said is it your belief that
only well-educated parents and make
proper decisions as to what's in the
best interest of their children
I'm sure though thank you for your
question and I appreciate of course that
parents in a democracy and particularly
in the United States public education
has been the means for people to move up
to greater opportunity for each
generation to be able to to succeed that
much more than their parents have and
you know you know my parents my father
didn't graduate from high school so
really wanted you know if it's really
important to him that I went to college
and so forth and each generation wants
more and better for their their kids
when it gets into the details would my
father have known what courses I should
be taking I don't think so and I think
that it is that ability to you know the
next generation to move beyond the
knowledge of their parents and I think
that's what we offer through the school
system thank you very much senator
representative Cordell you sold your
hand up yeah just follow to that so
parents that are not that well educated
cannot make those decisions and those
decisions as to the details should be
carpenter and you want to become a
carpenter then yes listen to your dad
all right we're gonna we're gonna we're
gonna move on anybody else have any
questions for the senator all right
seeing none senator deej thank you very
much for for joining us this afternoon
considering this important topic because
we really we do want to have more
extended learning opportunities and we
want to our parents and our teachers to
be involved terrific
something we can all agree on there
great thank you very much senator I
let's see I believe we we did have a
representative from the New Hampshire
elo network that that may have indicated
they wanted to speak and if Miss Couture
is the yes she is here I will move her
to panelists now I mean it
you know only if she wants to speak said
that she's available to
to speak senator Kahn also emailed and
requested to speak oh okay I'm I'm happy
to bring senator Khanna I don't want to
hold senators up on this can we can we
leave
senator Couture in there and bring
senator Kahn welcome again Thank You
Spearman I think everybody heard now
Jake on from Keene Senate District ten
thank you for inviting me to speak on
this amendment this is the the action
that the Senate joint resolution that
you previously adopted or recommended
ought to pass this is the action that is
suggested in that legislation excuse me
I got a mute that Senate hearing
representative lead so the you know I
this this does navigate the straits that
we were looking for this says Board of
Education you do have a statewide role
you do have a perspective and you can
provide valuable leadership and service
to local school districts and it says
what is in the remainder of 193 E that
local school districts you can choose if
you want to adopt this it does not
mandate that a student presents a third
of their credits from someplace else and
that a school district has to take it
which is what to learn everywhere rules
stated you have no choice school
district if a student has completed it
you must accept it this navigates the
streets it says
of Education it might be a statewide
role local school district you can
preserve your local autonomy and
determine if that's something now what
if you had students that took something
like son under each sub and they don't
do well with it
and you at repeated itself several times
local school district really ought to
have the authority of saying now it's
our determination it didn't work well
for us
the commissioners own testimony on the
learning everywhere was that well maybe
we'll use this for gymnastics or music
education well you can imagine that a
school district might have higher
standards for a gym credit or a music
course or then another statewide
provider of them and and not allow that
but that's the local school districts
determination but even more important to
the workforce development things is if
you are working in concert with local
school with local employers don't you
think that a local school district
really ought to determine that that's
where their link ought to be is with
local employers and they can choose that
and develop their own yellow or
internship or work based learning kind
of course and do that without having to
accept and and have their resources go
elsewhere their students go elsewhere
and that's a school districts option to
try to deliver things and encourage that
kind of development so I think I think
what senator deechi has proposed is is
the bill that then puts us on a course
that I hope it can gain bipartisan
support become the law and can be
implemented
by the State Board of Education Thank
You mr. chairman
great thank you very much senator
questions for um for senator Kahn going
once going twice
senator thank you very much for for
sharing your thoughts Thank You mr.
chair
Thank You Kim right and then next I'd
like to to invite Donna Couture from the
New Hampshire elo Network and Donna
you're already in so welcome to the
house education thank you for having me
I sincerely apologize for my technical
difficulties earlier in the meeting but
I'm happy to join now and no need to
apologize and we moved through this
thank you thank you for your patience of
course and thank you for yours I love to
be able to open for the record my name
is Donna kajoor and I do represent the
New Hampshire elo network as the former
president I worked with our current
leadership team to draft our testimony
today so that was provided in writing
but I wanted to just step in and echo
what senator Kahn and senator deechi had
already testified to we as at the
network wholeheartedly believe that the
school has the an important role to play
in allowing students the flexibility and
support to be successful in these work
based learning type activities these
alternative opportunities for students
we've gone so far as to create a high
quality framework for our yolo
coordinators around the state which is
very rigorous and provides guidance to
our Yolo coordinators in from anything
from the partners that should be
involved in heal in an elo the
monitoring the assessment all the way to
awarding
but what it also allows for is the
flexibility for districts to respond
based on the needs of their communities
the values and graduation requirements
that those individual districts
districts have that being said we face
as many of you have pointed out
districts who do not have the resources
available to hire full-time elo
coordinators now we have seen an uptick
in a and and we are we are adding more
elo coordinators in a full-time capacity
every year and that's really great but
we still have districts who are who are
struggling with that and so what we've
created with our network are these
regional regional networks where we have
regional chairs appointed and they're
veteran elo staff members who can
provide guidance and structure for those
districts who don't necessarily have
somebody full-time in place oftentimes
the responsibilities are added to the
plate of a school counselor or another
classroom teacher or the like and so we
are trying to provide those structures a
statewide that are gonna support
districts to carry these out it you know
when we first heard about learn
everywhere it was disappointing to see
that that level of support from a
school's perspective was missing and we
can provide you with a number of
examples as to why but I think the
bottom line is students don't
necessarily enter these work based
learning experiences with the skills to
navigate them effectively and so the
whole point of engaging in these
experiences is to make sure that they're
developing those skills throughout the
process and so I'm referring to things
beyond the skills required to do the job
I'm referring also to those soft skills
and so we repeatedly meet with those
students on a regular basis to discuss
things like you know problem-solving
communication teamwork something it
could be something as simple as how do I
talk to my supervisor about questions I
have or how do I address a confrontation
I encountered so those kinds of things
are absent from the process of approval
and without the sub
part of the network and the structures
we've put in place for Regions I don't
know how other schools will be able to
navigate them if students bypass the
school and go directly to the business
or industry to seek out these
experiences
it lends itself to a whole host of
liability issues we also as a network
are pretty stringent on how we guide our
elo coordinators and programmers to make
sure those employees and those business
industry partners are vetted we go
through Department of Labor process for
that and some districts go beyond that
and and do and have a number of other
safeguards in place to make sure that
those students are vetted that being
said if a business is approved through
those processes it is still on the point
of the elo coordinator to make sure that
that is the best fit for that particular
student and that's only done on a
one-to-one basis and so if for example
if it's if a larger industry or business
partner is approved yet a smaller
environment a more intimate environment
is better for this student that's
something an elo coordinator will know
and be able to help that student guide
through so these are again just some
examples that I that we can speak to
where we feel it is in vital for the
school to be a part of this process and
moreover we feel it really necessary for
the Department of Education to help
leverage these resources and provide the
support so that we can we can continue
to provide the professional development
and support to our districts in in
navigating these experiences for their
students terrific thank you very much
miss couture questions on this testimony
from members of the committee represent
core delhi mr. chairman and thank you
for being here i'm just curious with
your explanation of the the network and
all how is it that we only have 2% of
the eligible students receiving credits
laws well I can't speak to that that
number and and where that came from I
can say that there is some conflict with
the data that the Department of Ed
currently has and is using to gauged elo
implementation across the state we've
had some other sources of data that is
again conflicting to that so so I'm not
going to necessarily speak to the two
percent of our students I will say this
however there is a lack of cohesion
between for example the data and how we
capture it in terms of students who
engage in things like CTE our our career
tech ed programs and the work based
learning that goes along with that as
well as students who are engaging in
yellos and even if you throw in online
learning in the mix I think that it
leaves a lot of confusion in terms of
how it's reported and how that's
determined now that all being said I
think that we have we do have a long way
to go in terms of supporting our
districts but I do not think by any
means that we are going to get there
through they learn everywhere initiative
I think what we the way to get to
increasing access for students in these
programs is to support our districts so
you know specifically those districts
who can't afford or don't have the
resources to provide a full time elo
coordinator we need to be able to work
with the structures they do have in
place to support these programs
alternatively and and so there's methods
to do that and I think I just do not see
how they learn everywhere program will
get us there additional questions for
Miss Couture going once going twice
thank you very much miss Couture for
your testimony this afternoon for your
patience thank you very much for having
me have a good afternoon
all right you as well thank you Jen do
we have anybody else do we have any do
we have any additional cards
from anybody else only other possibility
that I have on my list is any a New
Hampshire they didn't indicate if they
wanted to speak in their written
testimony but they are here and they did
submit testimony perhaps if the NEA New
Hampshire representative could raise
their hand if they would like to
participate in the meantime it looks
like representing Eliot has a question
all right represent Valley yes yes I my
power cord was out and I went black for
a while there but I'm back on I just
want to make sure you could still hear
me okay we got you loud and clear
right so what we're gonna do next
seeing having no nobody else no other
red cards we're gonna close the public
hearing on on Senate bill 514 and we're
gonna proceed into an exec session so
let me pull up our exec session so are
we ready to go in this direction Jen yes
okay terrific so we get there as quickly
as possible this is the house exec we're
gonna be calling to order Shirley a
House Education Committee executive
session it's due 92020 and as chair of
the House Education Committee I find
that due to the state of emergency
declared by the governor as a result of
the coded 19 pandemic and in accordance
with the governor's emergency order
number 12 pursuant to executive order
2020 to zero for this public body is
authorized to meet electronically please
note that there is no physical location
to observe and listen contemporaneously
to this meeting which was authorized
pursuant to the governor's emergency
order however in accordance with the
emergency order I am confirming that we
are a providing public access to the
meeting by telephone with additional
access possibilities by video or other
electronic means fact we're utilizing
zoom for this electronic meeting all
members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting through this platform and
the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
clicking on the following website
address HTTP colon slash slash zoom dot
u.s. /j slash nine nine two seven one
seven nine three seven three seven or by
dialing on numbers one nine to nine to
zero five six zero nine nine or one
three zero one seven one five eight five
nine to be providing public notice of
the necessary information for accessing
this meeting we previously gave notice
of to the public of the necessary
information - for accessing the meeting
including how to access the public
meeting using zoom or telephonically
this information is printed in the house
calendar see providing a mechanism for
the public to alert the public body
during the meeting if there are problems
with access if anyone has a problem
please call to 7 130 600 or email at HC
s @ l EG dot state dot n h dot u s and d
a-- during the meaning of public access
if the public is unable to access the
meeting in the event the public is
unable to access the meeting the meeting
will be adjourned and rescheduled I'd
like to introduce the staff that are on
the meeting assisting us we have Jen for
House committee researcher and she is
the meeting host additional House
committee service staff providing
support of Brad Greenland Pam smiling
and Kristina Dyer um I just want to say
right now thank you all very much for
for your diligent efforts on this this
is no doubt an enormous amount of
logistical work and and and thank you
for your dear attention all of us this
is an executive session on Senate bill
514 a public hearing was held in this
bill earlier today copy the bill and any
other relevant materials have been
posted on the main page of the General
Court website under the heading remote
meetings please note that all votes that
are taken during the meeting shall be
done by roll call vote so let's start
the meeting by taking a roll call
attendance when each member states their
presence
he's also state whether there is anyone
in the room with you during the meeting
which is required under the right to
know law so with that I'll open the the
executive session for Senate bill 514
and ask the clerk to call the roll call
for attendance mary heath here in
Manchester I'm here alone and I'm
representing male representative Mel
Miller
yes in Manchester
alone representative Ford and I'm in
yes sir male from Northampton here with
my two children and I apologize for the
[Music]
I'm here in conker alone I am here in
Bedford alone representative real garan
Goffstown by myself bill and Epping and
I'm in sent a Conway and my lovely bride
is in the house you're in Haverhill
present from Salem New Hampshire in my
living room alone I'm here in Goffstown
and my roommate is in and out of the
room representative wolf wherever
sedative Allard I remain sadly alone
here in Pittsfield for sight
representative Lucas
I am here alone in my car parked
underneath the cell phone tower in
you know reporting from Hopkinton here
with AHS elongated dachshund thank you
very much
represent Tanner for for that and right
now I would take a motion of ought to
pass from representative Tanner and
seconded by representative Leigh cool
so representative Tanner if you'd like
to speak to your motion Tamerlane okay
thank you yes I think this bill is a
great compromise bill it as
representative Deaton Conn
representatives senators Conn and each
both spoke to this bill actually takes
and rewards the ELO program and tries to
expand it by allowing the role of the
Board of Education and the Department of
Education to oversee to develop this
list and vet vendors and at the same
time it allows the local school
districts to remain in control of their
credits for graduation I think talking
to the school districts in my eight
towns all of them really think that
these alternative education experiences
are vital they really would like to see
and promote those experiences within
their school resources both at the
parent level and resources at the school
level often are restrictive and that's
that's one of the areas that we really
need to work on but I think it's it's a
great bill and and I encourage everybody
to support
thank you represent inner representative
Lane would you like to to add to I'm
sure I just am just a point I am was on
the North Hampton school board and heard
of the co-operative women come in high
school board when the elo program was in
development here and I saw just the
tremendous effect that it has had on our
students in our community and bringing
the community into the school and I also
have to compliment the school system on
creating an atmosphere of inclusion
around all of their appointments so I I
I know things sometimes start slowly and
can evolve and I see this is a great
step forward from where we're at right
now thank you very much for episode of
leg are there other members of the
committee that would like to share their
thoughts on Senate bill 514 I see
Thank You mr. chair
I think representative Ladd's initial
comments echoed some of my concerns
about the bill in terms of the confusion
about rulemaking and the proof list
maintained by the ball referenced
anywhere the data we received my
Regional School District did not have
one student receiving credits and I
think if you ask the taxpayers around
either money is not the issue so I am
firmly against this bill and any
revisions to the language that is
currently in statute further further
thought some members of the committee
preserve land yeah this thank you very
much representative this would be a good
bill if you deleted everything that's
new in the bill and just left it the way
it was
after graduation putting a period there
and be done with it leave the bill the
law the way it is it can work it is
working however it just seems to be a
turf battle between some that are in the
schools right now and in those that in
an allowing credit from other avenues
online community work all that should be
accepted if in fact the students meet
competencies and you know we moved into
this competency education and quite
frankly over over the last year from the
way we voted on several I just wonder
really if we truly believe in
competencies thank you further thoughts
anybody would like to share prior to
prior to taking taking up the vote
seeing none then then I will ask the the
clerk to to call the to call the roll
call in the vote the motion on the floor
is an ought to pass on Senate bill 514
motion made by representative Tanner
representative Ford yes representative
Ford votes yes representative Lee yes
representative Lee votes yes
representative Tanner votes yes
representative Ellison yes yes
representative Mullin votes yes
representative real yes
representative real votes yes
representative alone yes representative
Woodcock
yes representative Woodcock votes yes
representative Ladd no representative
Ladd votes no representative Kordell II
no representative Kordell II votes no
representative Eliot no representative
Eliot votes no representative Alexander
no representative Alexander votes no
representative wolf absent
representative Allard no representative
Allard votes no representative for
sights absent Lukas no representative
like us votes no chairman Liu no yes
chairman no votes yes my tally is 11
yeses and seven knows
Senate bill 514 is recommended from this
committee ought to pass so that will
I represent of Cordell Laney and the
committee report bye-bye you'll end up
represent Eric and and again if end of
the day Wednesday
send it to to myself representative
miler and and then we will do it you
know quick proof on them get them over
to to Gen 4 and they will be in the I
guess the one of the next versions of
the house calendar so great great well
thank you all very much I think the the
Education Committee has completed its
business sign off can I just ask either
you a question or Jenna question how am
I going to get into that Senate hearing
tomorrow there should be instructions in
the calendar
okay so it's public and then get taken
off yes yes so um so let me let me um
and I'm gonna sort of open it up for
some general discussion here but but
this tomorrow afternoon the Senate has a
hearing on on some House bills and and
some amendments to two House bills
starts at one o'clock if you go over to
the Senate calendar and I think Rick you
just did this for another here Senate
hearing right sorry that is correct
I just been a DNA's been dealing with
stuff but yeah it's all in the Senate
calendar for okay so I just as long as I
follow the instructions to go in and
indicate that I'm gonna I'm gonna speak
and whatever right right now now now for
the for for people who who I believe are
are speaking on House bills that went
through House education that are now
being taken up in the Senate let's see
we've got we've got the the let's see I
don't I don't actually have it in front
of me right now maybe I do
no I don't but there's the House bill
that that extends special education
services through for older students
through I think the end of age 21 that's
being taken up sue is one of the
sponsors on that bill so she's going to
introduce it there's the House bill that
created tuition free at UNH our
university system and the community
college system in new hampshire schools
for for children of of permanently
disabled veterans and that is going to
be introduced by representative roy and
represent a valid i think i reached out
to you as well on that and and bump bump
the third bill is is actually the
the the bill which would correspond to
Senate bill 5:14 its House bill Linda
and I'm missing the I'm not guessing at
54 14:54 you're the prime on that and
and so Linda's going to introduce that
in the house tomorrow and and so so
please feel free to to connect up with
that meeting put your put your name and
if you'd like to testify either way
these were these like I said bills that
all came through this committee and and
certainly two of those bills I think it
are very very strong bipartisan vote
I think the there will be a number of
amendments that are going to be going on
to House bill is it's 1558 the bill that
some for student services right and and
so of those amendments I believe will
include my understanding will include
the manifest hardship that
representative loud night sponsor
sponsored together and a number of other
things so so anyway that's that's what I
know Rick you got something yeah I just
you know if anybody want is testifying
one of our bills that coming out of our
committee but it's been added or the
intent to add various amendments on
remember when you're introducing a bill
you're only introducing our bill right
you're not seeing all those amendments
you don't speak to those amendments in
that process at that time that's right
that's a good point
thanks for thanks for raising that so um
so know those those will be Senate
amendments they may look work they may
be word-for-word a bill that came
through here but that's a that's a
senator that will be that will be
introducing that amendment to to a house
built it obviously if you want to speak
to the amendment even speaking to the
well I don't know Rick did how did they
do it on what you're watching right now
well you can't you can't add an
amendment on a bill in a hearing right
so it's gonna have to be an executive
session so it really kind of locks us
out you we can speak to the bill as it
came from us as you're the prime sponsor
or the co-sponsor of and and that that
you know or a committee member
representing this committee at that
meeting only on that portion of the bill
because the rest of its not on the table
yet so so I I think I'm sorry I just
mentioned that um there are some
hearings on proposed amendments tomorrow
so that will give you an opportunity
those proposed amendments are speaking
to the language you're talking about
right yeah that that's what I was gonna
bring up because I think like even the
one o'clock bill of 1558 which where sue
introduces it I think they've got that
scheduled that one and then the
amendment at five minutes later to have
a hearing on that and that that has the
manifest hardship and we build that I
was dealing with today which is HB 1 2 3
4 1234
there's over 70 different sections to
that bill now and and so there's a lot
to it it's almost looks like H before
right where you have you know pages upon
pages yep nope anybody else have
all right well you know this has been a
pleasure this has been a rare
opportunity to to be with you all in a
in a remote in a rowboat committee
meeting and and I think we're one of the
few committees that that's even you know
had some bills to meet remotely on so so
this is a I think a unique special
opportunity I'm
personally looking forward to Thursday
just to just to see people in person so
I really I wish you all well be healthy
particularly be healthy on Thursday and
and look forward to seeing everybody
with the Wedmore Center okay good we
good good all right cheers everyone